i wanna i wanna talk about something
that's uh serious and silly at the same
time let's jump to the story
from timcast.com snip for a shake
nashville hot dog joint giving out free
milkshakes with proof of vasectomy
so uh congratulations
i saw i saw this tweet where this dude
was like your children will be going to
school with immigrants and weirdo
conservatives right because liberals are
all removing themselves from the gene
pool here's here i'll just break it down
very simply for all y'all
more likely to have an abortions
substantially substantially less likely
to have kids substantially more likely
to get hysterectomies
vasectomies
um to get
whatever it's called the tubes tied yeah
ma'am we're really the party of fun over
there um more likely to sterilize their
own children yeah yeah
so
i just gotta say
the
liberal left is very unlikely to exist
as an ideology or tribal group in 40
years but i agree i don't know what
everybody's getting so worked up about
when they're chanting about like being
pro-choice and it's like they're really
just getting rid of it
that's here's the crazy thing not even
being a
dick i'm just serious conservatives
the reason why abortion was it was a
guarantee
that abortion that roe v wade would have
been overturned
anybody in the 90s could have just
looked at a simple arithmetic and been
like in 20 years abortion will be made
illegal why conservatives have kids
conservatives don't want abortion
liberals abort their kids they want
abortion to abort their kids the math is
simple over a long enough period of time
the voting bloc becomes more
conservative and then votes away
abortion
bringing back more liberals i never
thought that would be the main problem
with democrats is that we aborted all of
our voters
well that's why they want to bring in uh
more immigrants the funny thing is they
say that they're like we want to bring
in more immigrants we want to strengthen
our voting bloc and then when tucker
carlson says it they're like yeah he's a
racist uh-huh well of course that's the
magic word yeah of course
well even rbg was kind of against roe vs
wade i mean my opinion on it is you know
different than obviously what my show
does it's sort of do you know do what
you do
i don't care but
i just don't think that the the way
they're going about it right now makes
any sense at all well and when you
you know i talk about tribalism and
online fighting how so much of it is
fake and when you actually talk to
people who disagree with you in real
life you can figure out that a lot of
you actually do want the same thing you
know because you go on twitter and it's
like well one party wants to kill women
and one party wants to kill babies and i
think there are still a lot of people
out there who
they're not pro-choice because they're
pro-abortion but their pro-choice in
like really terrible circumstances um
and i think when the left started going
started changing it i think libby
edmonds tweeted this where she she had a
tweet where it's like when the left
stopped saying safe rare and legal and
started almost bragging and boasting
about abortions and possessions and
pushing that
look at all my abortions it gets a
little gross right and then it's like
all right well now people are going to
go even harder to overturn it um whereas
maybe it was safer when it was i got i
want to give you a little bit a little
bit of pushback yeah and i'm going to
pull up our good friend she went ahead
oh yes with the ground news blind
spotter i'm pulling this up quite
literally because it's actually a bit
that shoe did she was doing an ad for
ground news and she said you can use
their uh their blind spotter to show
where if where you consume your news
shoe one head on twitter 86 of the news
that she interacts with leans left 86
86 does that mean things she she
comments on comments on shares and it's
like washington post
and charlotte observer we'll go back and
we'll do this is what she did ben
shapiro
and ben shapiro is 40 right 39 left wow
so this is the issue interesting you go
to a conservative who's who's pro-life
and they will explain to you the policy
what they think of roe v wade and why
you go to a liberal and they'll say the
right are evil and they hate women
that's exactly that's what i used to say
i mean that was that was the
conversation i had with sheamus the
first time i came on the show i was
legit that's why i was asking you and
shamelessly yeah where i was like hey
can you tell me because i literally just
heard if you say you're pro-life at all
you just hate women right you want women
to give birth to rape babies and like
that's your life but so and that it's
all about jesus it makes sense that
these that they're more likely to
remove themselves effectively from the
gene pool and i'm not saying it to be
crass or anything but it's it's
literally true
oh yeah i want to see jamie's i want to
see jamie oh yeah this is good jamie's
changed a lot what's your what's your
twitter
it's my name this is just a way to plug
my twitter by the way oh my twitter it's
at jamie killstein no he's biased don't
[Applause]
what's your what's your twitter dude at
landau dave yeah
could i
can i just take this moment to say that
i think that needing to defend your eyes
look at this guy oh dave landau perfect
i love it perfectly balanced that's all
you should be that is what you want yeah
look at bias crowder over here huh can
you hear little can any can everybody
who calls me now a right-wing grifter
can i just send them over to this yeah
sure yeah yeah this
political blog spot what's called blind
spotters i don't know if that would help
the case it's a lot of sense
i don't oh no they're saying i'm a
right-winger oh i guess oh my gosh
it's because you interact with tim
caster the most maybe it's the only one
i've seen where it's the majority of it
is center but it's because you tim cast
i mean that's kind of gem cast that's
cool though
sour patch lids oh no yeah that's a
badge of honor
hold on i just always feel like you
should actually listen to both sides but
the one side is becoming really just way
too you know why this is also i no
longer try oh because you're already
you're trolling them no yeah that too
but also because i follow a bunch of
journalists
that's pretty much why i'm on twitter
yeah yeah exactly i think i think it was
actually the same time that's good so
yeah you look at me you look at ben
shapiro you'll get elon musk you look at
michael malus you look at even jack
posobik has got more left on his his uh
then leftists but it's obvious
it's it's this is the issue that's
always been with the left i'm still
disturbed that mine looked like gnome
chomsky was on twitter that was very
upsetting
yeah i think but that this is why blind
spotter is great you know shout out to
ground news you know we're not doing a
spot spot for him but this is the issue
when it comes to uh pro-life when this
is the issue when it comes to taxes yeah
they literally have no idea what they're
talking about well and by the way that
is kind of actually proof to what i was
saying where you know i was talking to
dave about this beforehand and
you know i've gotten a couple i mean
your fans have been awesome but i've had
a couple of my old school fans be like
i'm leaving or i'm not gonna support the
patreon just because i'm on the show
they haven't listened to me on the show
they haven't listened to what i said but
because i'm on the show i'm giving
credit to tim which therefore somehow
i'm like a trump supporter it's been
very weird messages and
that is how a lot of them
think where it's the second you
you know
talk to someone on the right you're
automatically a grifter you're
automatically supporting everything
they've ever said and
what i'm
really enjoying about talking to more
conservatives or people in the middle or
libertarians or liberals who are
disenfranchised with the left is i'm
just educating myself i feel like for
the first time ever because like you saw
my chart where i wasn't being sarcastic
when i was like i could tell me pro-life
stuff because i don't know like i just
learned about guns this year only
because i moved to texas um but it was
just i just had my talk you're given
your talking points these are the
talking points you just shout whether
it's your racist whether it's you want
kids to die if you're pro-gun you want
women to die if you're pro-life blah
blah blah and then you just do those and
you just try to shout as loud as you can
and then you get retweets and then you
go to bed sad and depressed and that's
it sounds great it was a sweet life yeah
i just want to say real quick before we
move on i think the case can be made
that encouraging diversity of viewpoints
like the right wing does much more than
the left does and the right has to
defend their views much more than the
left does it's much more of an echo
chamber on twitter for the left wing but
i think that encouraging that diversity
of thought is going to mean the literal
difference between life or death as far
as demographics go we're going to keep
right-wingers alive what i think this
proves is that if you are a balanced
individual you are right-wing and if you
are in a cult
i don't know i i fall center like i had
62 percent sent but i don't think you
need to pick a side but that's because
you actually don't do a lot of news it's
like timcast.com
i don't click on a lot of political mags
that's for sure look my point is
all of these right-wing personalities
ben shapiro he his news is from a
balanced perspective and they're like
he's far right uh michael malus he's new
right and he's he's more he he consumes
more left that news than i do
oh absolutely so if you are someone who
gets your news from from a mixed batch
and you've formed your opinions off of
real information you are considered
right wing
that's insane the left are people who
are in echo chamber who have no idea
what's happening in the world and the
right is everyone else
oh absolutely well i assure you too like
we looked at crowders it's probably
because when we look at our show all day
we all watch cnn we all watch every bit
of left-wing media because we have to
look at our side against that so that's
the only thing we consume all day is to
see what their site is we don't watch
any other news source than that so i'm
sure by the time he jumps on twitter
it's like all right well what's this
this and this you know to kind of see
where those certain talking points are
for me
like when i got into you is because
somebody who
had a viewpoint i had where i always
felt that i was i was left i was always
raised in that kind of a
group friends whatever i just thought
the world was a certain way
i i don't even know if i'd say right or
whatever this is now i just know that
it's completely gone to a place where
i have been pushed over to this side in
the business that i'm in being a
comedian wanting what i want like we
were talking about punk music like
johnny rotten said he never thought he'd
live to see the day that you know the
rights were the ones giving the middle
finger to the establishment where trey
parker said that the right is the new
new punk rock it's just different now
it's shifted because it's gone so far
the other way that that is anything that
you say is just completely unforgivable
and 95 percent of the internet outrage
is for currency not because they
actually feel anything i really but
that's that so i view that as the
exception on the right and the rule on
the left yeah yes the right has a whole
bunch of people who are genuinely saying
like here are my thoughts my and then
the left has the majority of their
prominent figures are what do i have to
say to rile people that's right
david the right has those people but
yeah they do it's it's the exception not
the rule and the left has some good
people who make points they believe in
but they're not the most prominent um
dave as a comic was there i don't really
know what was there like a transition or
like a a creep moment for you because we
were talking about you were opening for
chappelle when chappelle was doing stuff
against george bush and all this stuff
when did
what did you just get the gig at
crowders as a gig and then it started
happening or was there like a creep well
i was at anthony comey's show who i
always loved from opiates that's right
and i was there for years and i was
already then and i used to sub mike
malice's show all the time because he
would go
on the road to different shows and
everything and i'd just like doing his
show because like i just turned it into
just kind of like a weekend update
you know dick jokes that mike would
appreciate and make it as dark as
humanly possible
and uh i always like doing that but
because i joined that network all of a
sudden i had people angry at me because
of something that anthony didn't
actually say but was said that it was
sad right a guy who was patrice
o'neill's best friend a show everybody
wanted to be on who all of a sudden was
an outcast that's what i grew up on i
grew up on all of the you know yeah i
was right i was opening for patrice who
i went to found out about if it wasn't
opinion anthony and all those guys yeah
and anthony is one of my heroes so now
i'm sitting next to one of my heroes and
you see this this bitterness come out
where all of a sudden it's like well
that guy's racist that guy's this that
guy's that i can't believe mike mouse is
all right it's like no you're just you
don't understand anything and you just
want to be enraged either by the fact
that i'm doing something that you want
to do or because somebody else has told
you something that you want to believe
yes and what but you weed out who your
real friends are very very you're
telling me for sure and i've learned
that through even being on crowder
crowder and i clicked his dad grew up in
detroit kind of by uh where i did and we
we connected that's how i met stephen
and as a result of that yeah i've caught
a lot of crap for it but at the same
time i've gotten a lot of great fans
from it and a lot met a lot of good
people and that's just part of this i
mean that's just part of this game with
jamie it was actually a really
interesting transformation i remember we
first met he was protesting one of our
events and he threw a brick at me right
yeah and then we brought him inside and
he was like i will i will always be your
rival and enemy and then i hand him a
check and he looked at the number and
said i'm pro-life one yeah yeah
yeah i i actually wrote mega on the
brick he got on the phone he was told
his girlfriend to keep the baby
that was actually a joke we did on cass
castle away
jamie's like i'm not going to these
right-wing events and then was it carter
yeah he's like oh that's a bummer
they're taking a private plane i'm like
you know what i got to bring everyone
together yeah
i was throwing a milkshake at a gay
asian reporter right
did you get um did comedy clubs ever
try to stop you or because you had a
following from this new audience they
didn't care and it was just more people
on twitter um at first for a second they
did and then uh
like somewhere like well i don't then
tickets were being sold and they were
like i don't mind no big deal yeah
exactly everything's i am loud with
crowder as well yeah yeah it's it's all
business and people have and i remember
my buddy freddy's a black dude who runs
uh hartford connecticut not to say race
but it is important to the story there
were proud boys standing in line and i
was like oh i don't know if that's a
good look and he goes why they're not
allowed to laugh and i was like why do i
say anything yeah it's just because it's
all a business when you break it into
the actual reality of a situation so
what uh what what i'm really interested
in doing is we we've got we've got tim
cascade boards we that we just we just
designed we've got uh step on snack and
find out it's like just like the t-shirt
yeah and then we have some some stock
just like it says like tim cast it's
like i've sent them to skate shops
because i mentioned this before if you
have skate shop and you want some free
boards we're going to send you free
boards and you can sell them for
whatever you want uh skate shops mind
you
and uh i want to put on contests and so
i've had a conversation with some people
about contests and like oh man you know
people might be worried about like the
politics and i'll be like we'll do a
massive cash prize like we we obviously
can't rival some of the biggest cash
prizes but we'll get a couple grand up
there so it's like it'll it will it will
be a contest people like you know like
that's a couple grand for a day's work
you know or more
and uh i was told yeah but some people
might just be like um it's not worth it
because you're gonna make maybe 40 grand
in contests this year and you do that
one for five grand dollars like 10 grand
first place
wow
now all these people who might
pretend to have political convictions
might be like
oh and by the way can i order like my
yearly income in one day
come on down to the skate count we're
not gonna do anything crazy we're not
gonna be political we're gonna have a
regular old skate contest but we're
gonna do a good cash prize big event
bring out the families get everybody
invited and we'll see who really is
gonna put their money where their mouth
is exactly well and also
the frustrating thing for
what i try to tell people the ones who
are bailing on me for being on the show
is
i've already
had i've been on the show what this is
my fourth time in a couple weeks i've
already had fans come to my show who
discovered me on here who didn't know
about me or discovered me on here
and
what the left doesn't understand is now
i have a room full of liberals and
conservatives and some stuff i say makes
fun of liberals and some stuff i say
makes fun of conservatives and a lot of
stuff i say makes fun of me and we're
all laughing together that is what you
should want you should want
conservatives to hear my view you should
want um liberals to hear my view when we
do just stay in this echo chamber just
to feel good about ourself you're
actually not convincing anyone that's
why there's so much infighting on the
left and you because they have they have
no one else to argue with because
they're they don't even talk to
conservatives or moderates so then they
just like eat their own
resistance it's a natural part of of
existence we need resistance to survive
if a tree doesn't have wind resistance
it falls over and dies yep it makes it
stronger we need that yeah and part of
comedy should be it should feel a little
icky at times like you want to feel a
little evil and fun like if everything
you say is supposed to be offensive or
is never offensive why is it why you go
to comedy right it's supposed to feel a
little bit too much yeah that's what
it's
why would you go to something that
triggers you right right like why
here's the deal like here's the deal fat
look fat uh
with these comedy things you've got
these millennials who
are
fluffy pink and un
and un callous right squishy yeah
squishy and frail they their parents
took care of all the problems for them
they grew up in the epitome of luxury so
they've never actually been struck for
any reason not at all no one should be
but it kind of happens for me it should
be yeah well so i know what you mean no
i i've tweeted that everyone should work
retail get punched in the face and one
more thing i don't know sometimes that
can all happen in a day working week
here's my point these people are soft
yes so when you say a mean word to them
it's the most pain they've ever felt so
to them it's like you have caused me the
most pain i've ever experienced
growing up in the city you get into
fights i don't care if someone says
naughty words to me right but what
happens then as they go to a comedy show
the most
comedy they've heard is probably like
teen titans go or you know fairly
oddparents or powerpuff girls yes so
they're watching these goofy little
cartoons where the joke is that someone
spilled milk and then cried and it's
like he crying over spilled milk oh it's
so funny then you go to a comedian and
he says he calls you an ins he calls you
a slur and you're like
and it's like he punched you in the gut
it's the worst pain you've ever
experienced they lose their minds well i
finally started reading uh cuddling the
coddling of the american mind and you
know some of these college protests when
they were protesting milo or protesting
ben shapiro they were literally saying
we have to use violence because their
words are violence against me and it's
like they're not violent so yeah that
concerns me you could break someone's
eardrums with a loud enough noise in
that instance
volume amplification can be construed as
violence but the definitions of the
words are not violence no of course
marilyn or not marilyn manson uh what's
his name charles manson sorry maryland
you can incite violence with words but
the words are not violence violence
happens as a result of the incitement of
the usage of the peaceful form of
communication yes
absolutely
comedy's just fun when it's edgy man i
mean the stuff we grew up you're
supposed to have an edge that's the
point your edge may not even be dirty
though i mean that's the thing
steven wright has an edge it's not a
dirty edge but it's an edge yeah i mean
there's there's an edge to everything
yeah you can do really good wholesome
comedy absolutely but it's not i'm just
kidding oh no but talking about poop
like you got to be able to talk about
the dirty stuff too you have to i really
george carlin had like the hippie to be
weatherman yeah you know what i mean it
was it was non-offensive it poked at
nobody it was not edgy at all it was a
good bit it was just an impersonation of
a silly weatherman and it was a trend
you know it was him trying uh sort of
evolving from that two-man group that he
was in and getting into this new hippie
phase and oh yeah and then all of a
sudden he stopped telling jokes and
started just railing on the federal
government
tim i'm glad you brought up carlin too
because it's been so interesting on
twitter in different
different times in the last couple years
seeing the right use carlin to hold up
their point or then seeing the left use
carlin to hold up their point and it's
like that's how you know he was good
that's how you know he was good he he
was just speaking his honest thoughts
and if the right can grab on to it
because it's something he said about
free speech cool if the left can grab
onto it because something he said about
environmentalism or abortion cool he
wasn't trying to pander to either side
he was just being him thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there